yeah i got in trouble uh because like
the pr i just drive a van now it's like
a regular looking sort of van
but the van i had a van i had before
was uh i'm probably gonna do this with
my current one because i've okay so
drift people the thing is stickers right
like i guess it's like i mean a lot of
cut you know things do that too but like
you know you meet someone here's my
sticker here's your sticker yeah yeah
yeah
i got a huge collection i've done like
sticker sorting streams on twitch and
like three of them wow so it took like
six hours i guess to do them all um
so i i put them on the rear door of the
gate of the car on the back when you
know whatever
i'm sorry and uh i did that my previous
van which i saw a while ago and
unfortunately one of them i stuck on i
didn't read what it said
it was written in japanese it was an
australian uh drift team because
they put like random [ __ ] on there yeah
and it said uh
what did it say it said
something like that like oh my god can
you translate that first
i guess it was like some they were
trying to be edgy or something because
it was like one of those sort of okay
so a lot of this is the one country
where you shouldn't have a sticker like
that yes
a lot of anime a lot of uh again this
crossover thing
there's a lot of these like sort of
anime style slap stickers that they make
like they have like some
random anime titties and like some team
name or whatever yeah and they've done
this and i didn't check what it said
because
again they came to fbc circuit like a
lot of foreigners come to mbc circuit
and they stuck it on there
and i didn't read it and then and then
my wife saw it
he's like what the [ __ ] is this
and i'm like what she has this sticker
here i'm like
yeah and i'm like i i didn't want to
peel it off because it was stuck on the
paint because it probably would have
peeled the paint off
yeah i got like a black marker
so i want to get it
i have like a [ __ ] irrational fear of
stickers like what what i have no idea
the thought of stickers you know how
like people used to when you're in
school
people just put stickers on each other
yeah they used to be disgusted and
people did it too why
it's like no i don't know just [ __ ]
freak me out people putting stickers on
me i'm like that's disgusting get that
off me
i hate stickers they are like the worst
thing ever magnets i'm cool with no
problem
stickers gross i don't know why what is
it like the stickiness of it i think
it's the stickiness the sound i'm like
that's disgusting get that away
get that away from me say the sound the
stickers make i [ __ ] you know you
don't put any stickers on
any of your products or anything on my
laptop
it was a gift and i felt bad not to but
a part of me it pained me so [ __ ]
really
well all conor fans uh next time you're
out [ __ ] give him stickers give him
stickers
i know what i'm getting for your
christmas present now connor you're
getting your sticker book for yourself
i've said that
i should have kept my irrational fears
to myself that's like going in front of
an audience being like this is my
weakness
i also have a weakness of money uh i
can't stand people putting money in my
pockets so if you want to
sorry it's called it's called patreon
i can't stand it connor you're like the
one you're like the one guy who's like
most into cars there now
you can't be a drifter now because you
don't like stickers do they put that
would piss me off speakers is the
main thing if someone came up and put a
sticker on my car like what have you
done i'll probably
ruin my car people do that okay so my i
have at abc circuit i have a skyline
that i
actually i leave it there like it's my
car that i drive when i go there
and i've told people like on you know
hey if you if you come debbie sue
just put a sticker on my [ __ ] that would
drive me up the wall i don't [ __ ]
touch my car
that's just how you make friends that's
how you bond like this stickers is not
consent
i'll stick your card if you stick my
card bring a plastic sheet right now
right put the sticker on that at the
moment [ __ ] rip that off
i didn't know that wow yeah no it's i
got them i have people like you know
it's a tourist attraction like they send
me selfies drift car like
yeah yeah because it's sort of like i
guess sort of semi-internet fighter i've
never been so horrified in my life
oh you can't be a drift driver then if
you don't listen you know you're gonna
have to give up a battery
after i did the drifting i was like
telling the boys i was like you know
what i actually think i'd get into this
it's pretty fun but first you have to
get over your irrational
fear of stickers i want to put that
aside
the worst thing is like so when you when
you buy tires and because
you know drifters usually they fit their
own tires then you save money
uh tires have a big sticker on them it's
so like the brand
you have to peel it off like peel it off
and i can do that i can get rid of them
you want to put it on hey people who put
stickers on things uh okay it looks so
tacky as well it does i agree we can
hate it
i agree but it's like it's sort of like
a you know who you know
like you know if it's a badge it's yeah
it's like it's
almost like a laptop disgusts me when i
see it where is it
this man has so many [ __ ] stickers on
it it drives me insane
that's pretty normal it's like someone's
spreading their ass cheeks in front of
me i'm like get out of here
it gives me all the memories like i
remember when i got all of these
stickers
that's it yeah you you you know like on
on my videos i go to a workshop and they
were like oh can we put one on
there it's like i've been here i know
these people like yeah and i'm just a
guy who's just been never
i've never been given stickers or
anything like that i don't know do you
have to memory like
out of memory by following okay do you
do you buy stickers
sometimes yeah because i've never been a
guy to be like i see a sticker this is
this is what i need this is my memory
because
it's always the budget item it's always
the the pity item and whatever
it's always the t-shirts or anything i
guess we have stuff because there's a
there's a there's a sticker shop
actually in uh harajuku called b-side
label that i go
to quite often where it's like it's it's
these like really like some of those
stickers on there are from there and
it's just i don't know it's like really
cool designs like but then again
i was always like huge into stickers
when i was a kid like i was that one kid
who had like
books and books i can tell joey okay
joey has this off-camera obsession with
what he calls peelies
right like so so whenever i expose my
shading
it's so every time we get some some new
kind of furniture or contraption
to have like the plastic the plastic
feelings right you understand it right
it's like you have to
know people there's people who like it
and then there's joey you like i swear
to god he [ __ ] has a tenth of an
orgasm every time he does a single
peeler he's just like just gig can can i
can i do it
and he just he just does it slowly i'm
just like yo joey do you want me to
leave you alone for like five minutes
man like
dude it's i [ __ ] love it you
understand right especially when it's
like the clear stuff not that it's like
when it's that dark blue one
new phones i like it because you can go
all right no no you can't go fast with
it you gotta go slow slow
you gotta tease it you gotta tease it
you know it's gonna make that
look at that glossy surface underneath
yeah exactly see alexa get some i get it
yeah man is this is it some australian
things that we just don't get
to do and also when you're a kid right
people would always like when you went
to the hospital or the dentist they'd
always give you a [ __ ] sticker
and when i was like yeah i love that
when i was like six i was like bold of
you to assume i want this [ __ ] thing
on me
don't you [ __ ] dare i think i have
the exact same
fear of like irrational fear but not
with stickers but with like buttons and
badges
i don't like those i don't like badges
what do you mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the the the pin
badges because
i didn't get stickers i would get like
those pin badges and i'm like don't you
[ __ ] put that on
you [ __ ]
yeah i was never into the pin badges
because they like if you collect a lot
of them they just make way too much
[ __ ]
yeah like i never understood yeah i
never understand people who go to like
anime conventions and they like
buy the pin badges of of like if if
you're going to buy any anime
memorability why the pin badges anything
else perpendicular japan [ __ ] loves
pin badges i don't know what it is like
every
every single like you'll find like a new
anime series right and you're like okay
i'm
looking forward to when they release
merge of this and they're like all right
we've released merge of it
have a pin batch bro it's like i don't
[ __ ] want it it's like detergent of
like it'll be like a
[ __ ] ava slash detergent
like cross [ __ ] yeah uh promotion and
it'll have like
it's got a it's got a sticker of eva in
it and it's like people go [ __ ] nuts
oh yeah yeah what's wrong with you what
i mean i'm one of those who was like
hell yeah it's like the
the holy trinity of just useless anime
merchandise is stickers pin
badges and clear files clear files are
the [ __ ] words
no one needs this many clear phones yeah
i mean i i have a clear file full of
clear files so
i can't say anything but uh i just can't
end up using them because you know they
say it
says clear file but they're always got
some stuff yeah you can't do that
it's the unclear phone it defeats the
purpose of a clear file